Oh
ah
ah ah ah ah ah, a fresh frame
, I want to
see the
drama ballet heart or thought
about the desire to see all other social hawks.
This is what happened until the synchronization stage of
the rapper through quantum entanglement.
Boolet
I majored in film since he was in East,
and he was a director I liked very much from when he succeeded in acting, and he grew up in
Baum because he was able to develop them so much that the
number of solid workers was so honored All
products  Ida is a director who is very similar to any other director
.
Especially this time, the person named Go Se-won is
very similar to the director with his back. He
is a little smart inside, but his rotation is
deep, so he imitates his son.
There are a lot of works that I like. As I work,
I am
so detailed and sensitive, and
I think that everyone with brushes comes out like this as a result
, and it is fun to me, that sf mystery, and
then more of a family movie, so
everything is a girl  The seller
will do it I think the upload certification
is very optimized for this kind of work that has such a complex lock and mix. In
every scene, any thoughts or feelings to the director,
that color,
oh, smell, what, I think, do all of these things exist
?
You can see the feeling of space well at the age of the character, even to each makeup, but it was a work that
cuts through the amnesty that was a bit serum for me,
and
I think it will be an unforgettable experience Arthur
[Music]